show me how you keep still oh my god
this is all wrong with you
do you know time it is it is 8 o'clock
on a Friday look what we're doing what
boring what oh you dog what are you
getting this wrong give me that
hmm I'm reading a sex novel you're
passed out like a beached whale we just
we've never do anything wild anymore we
don't do anything what are you talk
remember the other day we went to the
Red Lobster what do we do we stole seven
to the biskits stuff that [ __ ] in your
purse if that's not well I don't know
what is it's me a Pinot yup Super Mario
it's not sexy no I pinup you know every
time I see you my nose get hard like
this wow look look how about this how
would I be Harry and you be her mind
hello Hermione I loved you in your
little sexy little sweater vest and your
slightly enlarged forehead
[Music]
Hermione's with Ron not Harry I know
that's the sexy part about it look
you're [ __ ] it up are you gonna do it
or not my name is Emma you know Madine
done is soft okay what let's try Hunger
Games happy Katniss Peeta look I don't
want to be Peeta
okay no because all he does is bake
cupcakes and [ __ ] look how about this
how about I be Katniss and you be Gale
no no because I got the whole bow and
arrow babe you don't think you know what
I'm trying okay I've been offered to be
a lesbian so just don't want to be that
boring vanilla couple what cool SEDs
were booked we are not vanilla okay we
haven't even given all of our options
and go yet how about how about we do
that whole Edward and Bella thing hmm
I'm Bella
I've heard you scared me what are you
doing here so late it I've been watching
you touching myself furiously as you
sleep so your man take come on I here
with me instead of standing there
littering big guy bill I love you too
but I can't I'm too powerful I don't
care
turn me into a vampire okay no you're
not no let's try it again tomorrow
if later on tonight I asked you to be my
girlfriend
[Music]
I asked you to be
that is the Hema seats help